cientos de personas asistieron a este
evento de caridad en sana yemen y
decenas murieron testigos describieron
como el personal de seguridad útil
disparó al aire en un intento de
controlar a la multitud impactando un
cable eléctrico que luego explotó
causando la estampida la escuela donde
se celebró el acto es ahora una escena
del crimen cubierta de zapatos y
manchada de sangre dos organizadores han
sido detenidos y las autoridades culpan
a la distribución aleatoria de fondos y
a la falta de coordinación de las
autoridades Los Rebeldes utiles que
dirigen la ciudad han prometido dos mil
dólares de indemnización a cada familia
que haya perdido un ser querido mientras
que los heridos recibirían unos 400
dólares la organización benéfica que
organizó el evento fue financiada por
lugareños adinerados distribuyendo unos
10 dólares por persona en concepto de
ayuda económica muy necesaria con motivo
del final de ramadán ocho años de
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas
gubernamentales respaldadas por los
saudíes y Los rebeldes utís apoyados por
Irán ha dejado al país tambaleándose más
de 21 millones de personas dos tercios
de la población necesitan ayuda
humanitaria 6 millones de yemeníes están
al borde de la hambruna y 2.2 millones
de niños sufren desnutrición aguda según
cifras de la ONU y las promesas de ayuda
se quedan cortas una y otra vez en una
reciente conferencia sobre promesas de
ayudas solo se consiguieron 1.200
millones de dólares de los 4.300
millones necesarios